merci d'être avec nous on est pas le
salarié pendant cette première
demi-heure sénateur les républicains de
la Marne président de la mission
d'évaluation et de contrôle de la
sécurité sociale et on va bien sûr
parler longuement de la réforme des
retraites vous avez examiné le texte en
commission hier au Sénat mais d'abord un
mot sur une autre actualité puisque vous
êtes également médecin aucun d'accord
n'a été trouvé entre l'assurance maladie
et les médecins qui refusent la
proposition de revalorisation de
consultation de 25 euros à 26,50 € et à
30 euros à condition de prendre des
engagements territoriaux François Brune
juge que ce n'est pas responsable vous
aussi non non je pense que les médecins
ont tout à fait raison si on veut
valoriser la profession très
particulière de médecin généraliste
c'est encore un médecin famille dans les
certains territoires et bien il faut
qu'il y ait une reconnaissance au moins
financière digne de ce nom quoi
véritablement si on veut faire en sorte
que nos jeunes aillent dans cette
filière qui a une filière
particulièrement compliquée j'en parle
en connaissance de cause avec d'une
prise des risques inouïe vous parlez de
la santé des gens et bien au fond au
moins qu'il y ait une certaine
distinction alors bien sûr que il y a
des missions qui sont des missions
d'ordre de service public les médecins
sont prêts à leur faut leur [__] la
paix les laisser s'organiser sur les
territoires et les rémunérer en
conséquence sinon il y aura plus
personne qui ira dans la filière
médecine générale et la faire va
s'aggraver ça veut dire les rémunérés à
quelle hauteur 26 €
une rémunération digne de ce nom-là et
faire en sorte que attention ils vont
démissionner c'est ces médecins là et
demain on aura une médecine à deux
vitesses parce que il y en a qui vont se
déconventionner c'est pas possible de
maltraiter comme ça les médecins
généralistes c'est pas un 13e mois il
faut pas mélanger les revenus et le et
le chiffre d'affaires et on a
l'impression que on n'a pas appréhendé
la
problème rencontré autour de cela on va
parler de la réforme des retraites
longuement puisque vous avez examiné le
texte hier en commission on fait le
point d'abord avec notre journaliste
parlementaire ça vient de chez
[Musique]
bonjour Sonia bonjour Oriane bonjour
Vanessa Barry et Samia a donc approuvé
hier en commission le projet de réforme
des retraites oui l'examen en commission
c'est une première étape très importante
avant toute discussion d'un texte en
séance publique toute loi est d'abord
débattue en commission le Sénat on
compte 7 chacune spécialisée dans son
domaine et on y retrouve des sénateurs
de tout bord c'est en fait une sorte de
mini Sénat qui va faire un premier
examen huis clos pour faciliter le
travail qui va suivre en séance publique
avec tous les sénateurs voilà pour ceux
qui ne sont pas tout à fait au courant
de l'examen en commission et c'est bien
ce petit point pédagogique alors hier
sur le projet de loi de réforme des
retraites c'est donc la commission des
affaires sociales qui examiné le texte
oui Oriane et sans surprise le projet de
réforme des retraites du gouvernement a
été adoptée en commission puisque la
majorité sénatoriale de droite et du
centre dont vous faites partie y est
favorable elle souhaite donc la voter
mais à certaines conditions donc le
Sénat a apporté plusieurs changements
notables au texte d'abord sur la réforme
sur la retraite des femmes et ont eu un
ou plusieurs enfants elles auraient
droit à une surcote sur les trimestres
cotisés après 63 ans alors je vais
essayer d'expliquer c'est un peu
technique vous me reprenez si je me
trompe donc les femmes dont je viens de
parler ne pourront pas partir à la
retraite avant l'âge légal de 64 ans
mais si à 63 ans elles ont une carrière
complète chaque trimestre supplémentaire
travaillait après cet âge sera majorée
de
1,25%. et donc pour une année
supplémentaire entre 63 et 64 ans ça
fait quatre trimestres majorés donc une
surcote au final de 5% c'est une
proposition de la droite sénatoriale qui
y tient beaucoup qui estime que ça rend
cette réforme plus juste mais pour la
gauche ça ne va pas du tout assez loin
regardez ce qu'on pense Monique Lubin
chef de fil des sénateurs socialistes
sur ce texte c'est
remettre ce que finalement la réforme
enlève parce qu'aujourd'hui quand vous
avez 62 ans et que vous décidez de
travailler plus alors que vous avez
atteint le nombre de trimestres
suffisant vous avez une surcote
donc là on vous donne la surcotte la
différence c'est que vous êtes obligé de
travailler plus moi je porte pas du tout
ça parce que ce que les gens nous
demandent aujourd'hui c'est pas des
surcottes c'est pas d'avoir plus c'est
de travailler moins en tout cas de ne
pas travailler plus on a compris René
Savary la gauche votre sans doute contre
votre proposition est-ce que le
gouvernement lui en revanche est
d'accord avec vous pour cette surcote
alors
deux trois petits points simplement
rectificatif un projet de loi de
financement de sécurité sociale comme un
progrès loi de financement ce n'est pas
adopté par la commission d'accord on
examine on modifie ce sont adoptés par
la commission les amendements du
rapporteur mais le texte qui est
transmis sur le texte du Gouvernement et
les amendements proposés adoptés par la
commission seront rediscutés en séance
plein air et c'est là qu'ils seront
inscrits dans le texte donc le texte qui
sort de la commission contrairement au
projet de loi habituel est un texte qui
n'est pas modifié par la Commission
deuxièmement en l'occurrence ça a été
adopté hier par la commission cet
amendement sur la retraite des femmes
très largement deuxièmement nos
propositions sont les propositions Unies
de la majorité sénatoriale c'est
véritablement tous ces amendements sont
cossignés à la fois par leur apporteur
général et par moi-même qui montre bien
la cohésion de la majorité sénatoriale
puisque ce projet de loi est celui pour
une partie que nous avions proposé déjà
depuis un certain nombre d'adénoses nous
restons constants mais notre vision
était différente nous pensons que pour
faire accepter un projet de loi qui est
quand même un effort collectif puisque
les gens vont quand même travailler plus
longtemps alors pas forcément deux ans
pas forcément deux ans plus longtemps
puisque de par la réforme Touraine qui
est votée aujourd'hui c'est 43 ans ce
qui veut dire que pour croire en trois
ans d'activité le départ de l'âge moyen
est déjà à 63 ans et demain quand la
réforme Touraine sera appliquée des 43
ans pour les générations qui vont venir
notamment la régie les rations 65 il va
commencer à être concernés et bien quand
ces générations sont là tout le monde
partira en moyenne au taux plein 64 ans
l'ajustement de la borne fera
effectivement travailler peut-être
quelques mois de plus mais permettra de
ne pas te faire des retraités pauvres
pour en revenir à ces à cette dimension
tout à fait importante ce texte manque
de compassion je dirais pour ceux qui
sont en difficulté notamment qui sont
usés par le travail et manque de
reconnaissance par rapport au maire de
famille qui travaillent qui élève les
enfants et ces mères de famille se sont
elles qui amènent à la société
effectivement de parler maternité
un système par répartition qui pourra
mieux s'équilibrer demain donc la
politique familiale est indissociable
d'une politique de système de retraite
par répartition la politique sociale
d'accompagnement des gens en mesure est
indissociable d'un système de retraite
par répartition c'est la dimension qui
monte à ce texte c'est pour ça que nous
avons fait des amendements qui me
paraissent tout à fait répand à ses
préoccupations est-ce qu'il vous suit
sur cette mesure oui le gouvernement
semble quand même appréhender ce type de
mesure ça lui paraît cohérent j'ai cru
comprendre que madame la Première
ministre était aussi associée à ce type
de dispositif puisqu'elle parle de de
bonification ce qui revient à une
majoration je voudrais vous expliquer
que
contrairement aux critiques que j'ai pu
entendre quand vous avez une carrière
complète à rester à 63 ans vous êtes
obligé de continuer jusque 64 ans dans
le calcul de votre traite vous avez des
majorations du ré d'assurance liées à
certains trimestres liés à la maternité
d'autres à l'éducation des enfants et en
conséquence si vous travaillez plus
longtemps il est tout à fait normal
qu'il y ait une récompense que ne vous
travaillez pas pour rien et que vous
ayez dans le cadre où vous avez ces
majorations une retraite qui soit
valorisée alors effectivement c'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et que le
retransmet de même et qui n'était pas
dans le texte de loi et si vous dites à
toutes ces mères de famille qu'elles ont
quel que soit le nombre d'enfants
qu'elles auront 5% de plus dans leur
bonification de leur retraite je ne suis
pas sûr que le bout de pas leur plaisir
et d'autre part tonique Lubin qui disent
à travailler moins mais sinon elle
travaille moins elles n'ont pas les 5%
donc le choix c'est et c'est pas
travailler moi pardon elle travailleront
longtemps puisque la loi c'est 64 ans
donc soit elles ont la bonification soit
l'ont pas la vraie question je pense que
c'est quand même une avancée d'autre
part on sait bien et Monique le ma aussi
on sait bien que il y a une différence
de rémunération pendant les carrières
entre les femmes et les hommes qu'il y a
une différence également de niveau de
pension atténué certes mais il y a
encore une différence dans le système de
retraite entre les pensions des hommes
et des femmes et les tout à fait
indispensable qu'on puisse réduire cette
différence les femmes sont encore
perdantes sont encore un peu pénalisées
comme le disait Francky il faut
reprendre ça parce que effectivement ça
dépend des tranches d'âge mais
progressivement de par le système
d'allongement de la durée de cotisation
les 43 ans si c'est c'est
dans la loi le texte il fait
qu'accélérer mais les 43 ans sont dans
la loi à la conséquence des 43 ans c'est
de bouger l'âge effectivement de légal
mais que de toute façon il y aura
derrière cette
évidence qu'il va falloir travailler
quand même un petit peu plus longtemps
un dernier mot là-dessus après on va
parler des autres sujets Samia mais
initialement Bruno Retailleau souhaitait
que les femmes et le choix entre une
surcotte ou un départ anticipé pourquoi
le départ anticipé ne figure plus dans
ce qui a été voté hier pour la
commission c'était un bon choix c'était
un bon choix parce que effectivement on
aurait bien on aurait bien pensé que
c'était encore mieux que ce que l'on
proposait
sauf que si on propose ça on est plus
dans les pure budgétaires en ce sens que
nous dans en tant que parlementaire nous
sommes soumis à un article 40 nous ne
pouvons pas générer de dépenses plus
importantes et là vous générez une
dépense brutalement plus importante par
rapport au système actuel c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons pas pris
cette option là et cette surcote vous
arrivez à la chiffrer combien ça va
ça représente sur les années
150 à 200 millions d'euros mais je pense
qu'elle est tout à fait légitime et on
va parler de la question des économies
dans quelques instants mais d'abord vous
avez aussi fait d'autres modifications
hier en commission Samia et notamment la
création d'un CDI senior oui c'est une
proposition là encore de la majorité
sénatoriale qui veut créer un contrat
exonéré de cotisation famille pour les
salariés en fin de carrière ça coûte
moins cher à l'employeur c'est donc une
mesure d'incitation pour recruter des
seniors qui pourraient par exemple faire
du tutorat
avec des plus jeunes salariés c'est une
pratique trop rare en France racontée
hier Elisabeth Doisneau co rapporteur du
texte au Sénat
quand même incroyable que dans un pays
comme le nôtre en soit aussi peu
efficace sur ce plan là notamment par
rapport à l'expertise que porte les
anciens dans une entreprise et qu'ils
peuvent transmettre aux futurs
générations et notamment aux apprentis
qui sont aujourd'hui importants en
termes de nombre et qui ont besoin aussi
de cette transmission de ce passage de
témoins voilà pour le CDI signor et la
majorité sénatoriale rétablit aussi
l'index senior supprimer par l'Assemblée
nationale pour rappel il s'agirait d'une
sorte de baromètre pour mesurer l'emploi
des seniors dans les plus grandes
entreprises avec des possibles sanctions
à la clé jusqu'à 1% de la masse
salariale vous avez donc rétabli cette
mesure en commission alors que on le
savait votre famille politique n'était
pas vraiment favorable à cette à cette
idée pourquoi vous l'avez rétabli parce
que nous sommes déjà en constructifs et
consensuels voilà on la rétabli mais
pour les entreprises de plus de 300
c'est pas un baromètre l'index c'est une
photographie
d'accord ce qui veut dire que vous avez
une entreprise qui a beaucoup de seniors
parce que elle a pas travaillé sur la
pyramide des âges au sein de son
entreprise elle a un excellent index
sauf quand elle va renouveler son
personnel qui partira à la retraite elle
est pas sûr d'embaucher des seniors son
index va se dégrader c'est pas parce que
vous avez beaucoup de seniors que vous
aimez les seniors quand vous avez une
jeune entreprise tournée sur les
technologies et bien embaucher des
jeunes parce que la formation de ces
jeunes sur les nouvelles technologies
les seniors l'ont pas acquises forcément
au cours de leur carrière donc elle aura
un mauvais index et la raison ça nous ça
nous paraît pas le meilleur choc mais il
faut bien que il y a une part des
entreprises quand même dans les forces
générales c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons accepté effectivement
personnellement à contre-coeur mais peu
importe nous avons accepté de faire
cette index au sud 300 salariés parce
que sinon c'est pas significatif mais
nous avons en contrepartie travailler
sur cette tranche d'âge qui est l'âge
des seniors qui arrive en fin d'activité
ce passage entre votre vie active et
votre vie sédentaire doit être
maintenant compte tenu
pris en compte parce qu'ils dire
plusieurs années voilà c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons proposé des
mesures pour le Seigneur qui est au
chômage il y a rien de pire qu'un
seigneur au chômage pour ce seigneur au
chômage nous proposons le CDI senior qui
permet dans le cadre d'un contrat
d'aller jusqu'à du départ en retraite à
taux plein du salarié pour celui qui est
en entreprise qui peut connaître des
difficultés la retraite progressive des
60 ans voyez-vous c'est une façon de
pouvoir continuer jusqu'à l'âge du taux
plein voilà l'accompagnement que nous
proposons et parallèlement pour faire en
sorte que il n'y ait pas assez
licenciement ces ruptures
conventionnelles qui se passe toujours
quelques années avant la retraite où on
met sur une voie de garage notre senior
et ben nous avons durci le forfait
social pour qu'ils puissent plus
important quand vous laissez aux
entreprises un choix
entre garder son seigneur elle davantage
pénalisé si vous
faites une rupture avec lui et ben je
pense que les entreprises naturellement
auront besoin d'oeuvre de l'expertise
des seniors et garderont ce senior donc
vous étiez contre cette index vous dites
à contrecœur est-ce que c'est une
concession pour pouvoir faire adopter
votre CDI seniors non pas du tout je
pense que tout le monde a été unanime
sur ce CDI seigneur je l'ai pas inventé
CDI seniors il a été proposé par des
syndicats salariés par des syndicats
professionnels par des interprofessions
ça m'interpellé je me dis il y a quand
même quelque chose et cette exonération
va permettre véritablement que le chef
d'entreprise ou à différemment justement
le Seigneur et se disent ben je suis
incité à le prendre pourquoi de le
prendrai-je pas
il y avait d'autres choses que
souhaitaient la droite sénatorielle et
notamment Bruno Retailleau c'était la
suppression l'accélération de la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
qu'est-ce que ça a donné hier en
commission Samir il y a rien au final
pas d'amendement de la Commission sur ce
point pourtant on le sait effectivement
Oriane la majorité sénatoriale elle veut
accélérer la suppression des régimes
spéciaux de retraite ces fameux régimes
qui permettent aux salariés de certaines
branches de prendre un départ anticipé à
la retraite comme par exemple le plus
connu celui de la SNCF donc le
gouvernement veut bien les supprimer
mais uniquement pour les nouveaux
entrants ceux qui seront embauchés après
la réforme votre famille politique là
encore René Savary elle voulait proposer
de les supprimer plutôt alors pourquoi
finalement vous n'avez rien proposé en
commission est-ce que vous avez eu peur
de durcir davantage un mouvement social
avec cette mesure non non mais je pense
que si vous voulez c'est un débat qui
pourra se faire en séance parce que
c'est un débat particulier qu'est-il
proposé actuellement par rapport au
régime spéciaux c'est de les fermer aux
nouveaux entrants c'est pas fermer tout
de suite le régime spécial ça veut dire
que ceux qui sont actuellement qui sont
embauchés cette année ils vont rester
une quarantaine d'années dans le régime
spécial ils vont avoir 20-25 ans de
retraite donc 65 ans s'ils sont mariés
avec un conjoint un peu plus jeune et il
y aura une pension de reversion ce qui
veut dire que les régimes spéciaux
seront fermés dans environ 70 à 80 ans
entre 70 et 80 ans et accélérer la
convergence dans quelques années ou
quelques dizaines d'années on doit
pouvoir trouver une marge de manœuvre
parce que sinon vous allez faire
travailler des personnes qui auront le
même métier
et qui auront des statues différents
celui qui va rentrer n'aura pas le même
statut la même rémunération non plus
parce qu'il faudra bien compenser que
celui qui est actuellement dans le
régime spécial je pense que c'est pas
comme ça qu'on fait en sorte d'avoir un
bon climat social c'est dégradants donc
entre attendre 80 ans et peut-être avoir
une convergence en ce qui concerne l'âge
de départ des sédentaires qui soit comme
la fonction publique ou le privé ça
choque sera personne ceux qui ont dans
des services actifs qui ont plus de
difficultés correspondant aux actifs de
la fonction publique doivent avoir le
même âge de personnes et bien on va pas
mettre 70 ans pour régler tout ça quand
même
15 20 ans c'est quoi la bonne échéance
la bonne échéance si vous me demandez à
titre personnel ou à la bonne échéance
c'est d'appliquer ce que l'on ce que
l'on applique au régime commun un
trimestre par génération où vous
travaillez à ce moment-là un trimestre
de plus au fur et à mesure de chaque
génération et vous faites une montée de
rapprochement en âge qui se fait
progressivement à partir de 2025 et vous
arrivez selon les régimes parce qu'ils
n'ont pas tous le même âge à une une
convergence peut-être d'ici 15-20 ans
c'est quand même c'est quand même un
délai qui me paraît raisonnable non et
du coup pourquoi parce qu'il y avait des
divergences avec les centristes sur ce
point je regarde bien quand même il faut
quand même bien regarder parce que comme
les âges sont complètement différents de
départ vous en avez qui sont à 54 55 57
donc il faut voir ceux qui sont à 57 car
il va 62 c'est d'autres entre 52
nos concitoyens ne peuvent pas
comprendre qu'ils peuvent être
traitement identitaires dans cette
affaire-là donc je pense que c'est tout
à fait normal d'ailleurs dans notre
amendement que nous présentons depuis
quatre ans dans notre volonté de réforme
nous avons toujours dit qu'il faut
accélérer cette convergence
oui là encore votre famille politique
n'a rien proposé en commission alors
qu'on le sait vous vouliez pousser pour
un départ plutôt pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt il vous allez
proposer des amendements en séance
écoutez cette gouvernement qui va
puisque la première ministre a proposé
de mettre trois bornes au lieu de 4
bornes 16 18 20 21 maintenant pour les
départs anticipés de carrière langue
mais après les âges sont définis par
décret en ce qui concerne également les
durées de cotisation mises en face de
ces bornes là aussi c'est par décret
donc nous allons dans les propositions
du gouvernement
il disait 43 ans pour tous les Français
qui sont dans un dispositif derrière
donc pour vous c'est pas envisageable
c'est plus à dispositif de carrière donc
si tout le monde fait 43 ans c'est un
dispositif de carrière précoce faut le
réécrire ce dispositif il est
complètement ambigu il est illisible et
vous traitez les façons les personnes de
façon inhaguée à terre pourquoi parce
que les trimestres pris en compte dans
un dispositif de carrière longue sans
moins solidaires que ceux qui sont pris
en compte dans un dispositif normal
alors si vous avez quelques mois
d'avance par rapport à vos 20 ans par
exemple vous êtes dans une dispositif ou
bien portant lui va faire sa carrière et
puis il y aura pas de souci il va partir
à 63 ans et puis le salarié plus fragile
qu'aurait eu connu un peu d'épisode lui
il va partir à 64 ans pour moi c'est
inégalitaire je comprends pas qu'on
puisse défendre ça c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut revenir à un dispositif
celui qui commence très tôt 18 jusqu'à
18 ans avant 18 ans 19 ans 20 ans
maximum sûrement pas aller plus loin et
bah celui-là effectivement il faut
prendre en compte la carrière
sur les économies puisqu'on sait que
vous êtes très attaché à l'équilibre
financier c'est avec les concessions qui
ont été faites par le gouvernement
l'équilibre en 2030 est encore garantie
où est-ce que vous allez chercher
d'autres économies bah écoutez il faut
effectivement garantir cette équilibre
mais les propositions du Sénat qui sont
véritablement des propositions sociales
qui prenaient en compte le Seigneur qui
prennent en compte les maires de famille
ne dégradent pas le le le rendement de
de ce texte enfin en tout cas de
l'équilibre de façon importante au
contraire ce sont par contre les les
propositions qui ont été faites avant
que le texte arrive au Sénat qui dégrade
l'équilibre budgétaire
un dernier mot puisque la majorité
sénatoriale souhaite aller au bout de
l'examen de ce texte souhaite qu'il y a
un vote la gauche pas forcément est-ce
que vous pensez pouvoir aller jusqu'au
bout est-ce que vous craignez une forme
d'obstruction de la gauche sénatoriale
on verra bien je crois que le Sénat doit
se différencier de l'Assemblée nationale
ça a toujours été comme ça on a toujours
travaillé les textes en profondeur dans
le plus grand respect les uns les autres
j'espère que ça continue comme ça parce
que c'est quand même un sociétal qui
interpelle les gens on le voit bien on a
essayé de prendre en compte un certain
nombre de dispositions nécessaires ont
bien aller jusqu'au bout merci René Paul
Savary vous restez avec nous parce qu'on
va voir l'actualité dans votre
département et je remercie Samia on
reparlerai de retraite et immigration
tout à l'heure ça vient dans le club on
finit par l'actualité du côté de la
Marne on va Reims on retrouve Grégoire
Amir tamassèvres et data en chef délégué
à l'Union l'Ardennais bonjour Grégoire
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous on parle
d'un autre sujet le dossier du jour et
qu'on s'est créé au salon de
l'agriculture
absolument depuis samedi et date de
l'ouverture du salon nous consacrons
plusieurs articles autour de cette
thématique de l'agriculture nous sommes
allés notamment donc rencontrer nos
agriculteurs qui sont éleveurs qui sont
au salon pour voir comment ça se passe
nous avons passé la nuit avec eux parce
que il y a une ville à nuit au salon de
l'agriculture évidemment puisque les
bêtes on ne peut pas les laisser comme
ça et puis évidemment aussi entre
agriculteurs ils se retrouvent tout au
long de la semaine on va continuer à
traiter ces sujets puis notamment on va
aborder un terme qui est très important
c'est la transmission de des
exploitations agricoles c'est une vraie
question puisque d'ici 2030 si je me
trompe pas la moitié des agriculteurs en
activité vont partir à la retraite et
une des vraies questions c'est de savoir
comment quelle solution faudrait-il
mettre en place pour essayer d'attirer
les jeunes vers l'agriculture c'est pas
si Monsieur Savary par rapport à cette
question vous avez des pistes à proposer
écoutez je connais bien mon agricole
dans mon département puisque il y a des
problèmes me sont directement trans pour
les faire remonter c'est vrai que c'est
un souci cette transmission c'est pour
ça qu'il faut valoriser la profession
agricole moi je ne comprends pas que
dans nos cantines par exemple la moitié
des produits que nous consommons sont
importés ce qui montre bien que en
France on produit pas assez donc il faut
faire en sorte que on puisse donner les
bonnes conditions et les rémunérations
nécessaires pour produire correctement
sur nos territoires et nous produisons
de plus en de mieux en mieux nous
importons des produits qui n'ont pas les
mêmes qualités et qui est dont on
connaît pas toujours les traitements
qu'ils ont eu pour faire pousser et
alors que en France nous sommes très
contraints et nous avons une des
agricultures les plus propres d'Europe
en conséquence la meilleure façon c'est
comme le monde médical la meilleure
façon de faire en sorte que les jeunes
s'attachent à ce métier c'est qu'ils
puissent vivre d'une rémunération sur
une rémunération correcte et que l'on
leur fasse confiance dans l'organisation
de leur travail qu'on arrête de leur
imposer er sans arrêt un certain nombre
de directives comme si on savait mieux
que ce qu'il faut faire sur le terrain
donc confiance au territoire et vous
verrez que tout se passera bien vous
allez nous parler du chèque vert
absolument la région Grand Est désormais
présidée par le marnais Franck le roi
vous connaissez vraiment bien ce Savary
a bien de lancer un chèque VR ce chèque
vert c'est pour aider les toutes petites
entreprises de moins de 20 salariés
également les artisans pour investir
dans des moyens pour réduire la facture
énergétique c'est vrai qu'au-delà de
cette aide que d'après ce qu'on voit
nous dans les artisans qu'on a pu
contacter les gens de la connaissent pas
vraiment qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait à
votre avis faire pour essayer
d'accompagner encore mieux tous ces
petits artisans et petits commerçants
qui sont durement éprouvés par cette
crise énergétique depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois oui et puis crise
énergétique notamment liée au coût de
l'électricité c'est quand même
incroyable qu'on soit obligé de faire
des chèques pour l'électricité quand on
sait que ton avis une puissance
nucléaire qui était extraordinaire et
qu'on a dégradé au fil des années qui
nous aurait permis d'avoir une
électricité la plus propre de toutes et
la moins chère des par rapport aux
autres et bien maintenant on fait croire
aux gens que on va les aider à travers
ce coup de l'énergie alors que on porte
des responsabilités puisque on n'a pas
su entretenir correctement nos centrales
nucléaires une fois qu'on a dit ça faut
accompagner notamment ses petites
entreprises parce que c'est terrible
elle n'arriveront pas à
générer des bénéfices donc elles sont ce
sont des entreprises qui sont en péril
derrière donc il faut mieux faire
connaître ces entreprises et puis ma
voix celui qu'on a pas besoin c'est pas
pour autant qu'il doit demander celui
qui arrive à se débrouiller mais celui
qui en a véritablement besoin il faut
essayer de le sauver et je salue cette
initiative particulière de la région
Grand Est parce que c'est une initiative
qui me paraît corresponde aux
préoccupations en territoriales merci
beaucoup merci Grégoire d'avoir été avec
nous regarde la Une de l'Union et de
l'Ardennais le salon vit aussi la nuit
nuit au salon avec nos éleveurs c'est à
la une de vos journaux merci beaucoup
Grégoire d'avoir été avec nous depuis
Reims et merci on est pas le Savary
d'avoir été notre invité vous reviendrez
nous voir à l'issue de l'examen du texte
pour faire le bilan